[Music]
that's jay-z
rapping about owning jean-michel
basquiat's painting
charles the first he's also reported to
have purchased the painting
mecca eight years ago for 4.5 million
dollars
a bargain when you consider that earlier
this year one of basquiat's paintings
sold for 93 million at christie's
another
for 51 million at sotheby's outside of
the auction houses basquiat's legacy is
also being celebrated on multiple fronts
including his role
in the early hip hop movement
this is the music video that
unexpectedly helped launch hip-hop
culture
into the mainstream featuring blondie's
debbie harry
rapping to jean-michel basquiat
[Music]
continuing past other graffiti artists
like lee quinones
he would use his spray paint to return
the favor
so this piece right here was done on two
aluminum panels
i told everybody to leave the room
including john i said get out
and i painted in about five hours it's
just it's gorgeous
and that was like a way of saying listen
guys this is bigger than us
you know we can bring it to a whole
other level the painting is part of the
exhibition
writing the future basquiat and the
hip-hop generation
at the museum of fine arts in boston so
early hip-hop culture
was a multi-disciplinary art form that
consisted of rapping
attention everyone my name is mighty
djing
break dancing and then the visual art
arm of it
was graffiti liz munsell is the
co-curator
this was a time that was transformative
and all these artists basquiat
included were the pioneers of
contemporary streetwear as we know it
today
i'm awed at the detail this is
jean-michel basquiat's 1985 portrait of
his friend graffiti artist
a1 so the sneakers alone are just
so fantastic and the trench coat the
beanie
he's just exuding style the exhibition
pays
tribute to post-graffiti art when
basquiat and his contemporaries
this is a 13 foot canvas use their spray
paint on canvas
instead of city walls or subways it is
a multi-part drawing that basically
depicts
the history of subway graffiti
it's pretty epic all these artists you
know were really
battling against being framed as
delinquents
as vandals for deciding to work on the
trains
the exhibition also places the graffiti
writers at the center of rap music's
origins
you're saying to yourself so this is
beatbox a track that
boscat produces in 1983 it effectively
becomes one of the most important tracks
in early hip-hop
history munsell attributes basquiat's
artistic break with his casting in the
movie
downtown 81. i've made my mark in the
world
and it's made its mark on me which gave
the young artist
access to canvas supplies and his own
studio
it's an absolute centerpiece of the show
pieces like hollywood africans would
help turn
basquiat into the figurehead of the
hip-hop artists
this painting is paying homage to hattie
mcdaniels
who was the first african-american to
win an academy award
for her role in gone with the wind he
really invented a
vocabulary all of his own through
choices
like gangsterism as well as heroism
he's talking about these dualities and
he's talking about the role
of the gangster that he's playing out in
the west coast art world
today basquiat is a conquering hero of
the art world
cemented in 2017 when this untitled work
sold for an astonishing 110 million
dollars
prompting one dealer to claim quote he's
now in the same league as francis bacon
and pablo picasso
basquiat would be 60 but died at age
27. he's buried in greenwood cemetery in
his native brooklyn
it's just a few miles down the road from
barclay center
where at various times this past season
the nba's brooklyn nets
sported uniforms and a court inspired by
basquiat yeah i mean he was a very
impactful artist
we had a chance to talk to the nets
kevin durant about it
a lot of guys said they want to try a
white jersey next year
the bosque jersey so we you know it's a
part of who we are
artists like that really are in our dna
as a team and as an
organization and as a city had you known
him of him before
yeah for sure knew his story tried to
look for some of his arts hard to get
but
it's good that we can represent him in
some way and have our own little art
piece on our jerseys as well
the nets also took the concept off the
court
partnering with the department of
education to develop a basquiat focused
art curriculum
for 1400 middle and high school students
in brooklyn
are you surprised at how your students
responded to this
i am art teacher tina stevens helped
11th grader ricky molina with his design
for this tote bag
cut it up we kind of stitched everything
and then a lot of pictures that i took
because i am a photographer
so like my name it's like rxky
it's all over the place everybody says
it has it changed
how you think of yourself as an artist
now yes the beginning of the school year
i was really going through like
a phase of depression because of school
and everything even though there's dark
spaces on this
there's still light here and there a lot
of people go through struggles
that think that they can come out of but
everybody can come out of that struggle
you guys met in person for the first
time today
yeah middle schooler vera montiel worked
remotely with her teacher
james hagerty this one is called
hollywood africans
this is an artist who has a lot of depth
here's a lot of symbols in his work
and i felt as if he really had something
to say and i wanted the students to
enjoy it
all of this is basically my identity
vera's work features her love of singing
her family and its ecuadorian heritage
and social justice would you have
put social justice in a piece of art
before learning about basquiat
definitely not
i did not see that as art but learning
about it
and how he was like he would always talk
about that through his art
that made me rethink that no this does
mean art this is our
i can put it in my work it makes art
even more powerful
yes artists like basquiat
and lee quinones didn't have access to
that kind of education in school
which once upon a time forced them and
their groundbreaking peers
underground most of us ran in the
shadows because we had to
but not anymore it's amazing to be in a
museum and see the work
just the way we wanted it to be
the exhibition in boston runs through
july 25th and the artwork of about 150
students will be on public display
at barclays center august 8th and 9th
that program was funded by the joe and
clara sci foundation part of the team
owners
social justice fund i have to say first
of all the artwork is amazing in boston
it's incredible to see in person
but those young children the kids the
teenagers yeah
to hear them just be ignited and
enjoying art and
seeing themselves and that they can be
artists in a different way you have to
find what inspires you
and this really spoke to me and
understanding that any expression of
yourself can be art exactly whatever it
is
yeah such an arc you did a great job
great job great job